une réunion pour préparer la fusion les
deux missions locales de plaisir et de
saint quentin en yvelines se sont
retrouvés au golf national ce mardi 19
décembre
objectif échanger sur le mariage entre
les structures prévues pour le 1er
janvier 2018 c'est important parce que
finalement à plaisir on a un peu plus
éloigné que les autres antennes les
jeunes des autres donc on se connaît pas
du tout et pour moi qui suis nouvelle à
plaisir depuis un an
c
les nouvelles rencontres le rendez vous
a également permis d'expliquer la mesure
qui sera voté au prochain conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines ce jeudi 21 décembre
la fusion est plutôt de fusion
absorption en créant une nouvelle
structure sera mis beaucoup plus de
temps
et qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait en effet
du service à rendre au public qu'est ce
qu'on aurait fait aussi des salariés qui
travaillent pour les jeunes en
difficulté à la sortie de ce rendez-vous
les quarante trois employés présents ont
accueilli cette fusion absorption avec
enthousiasme donc plus d'idées peut-être
plus de moyens
moyens financiers moyens humains et puis
peut-être plus en plus de sites où les
jeunes peuvent se déplacer aussi la
fusion sera intéressante pour les jeunes
de tout le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines qui auront tous en fait les
mêmes prestations les mêmes services
car je n'habite plaisir aucun je
n'habite par exemple voisins le
bretonneux
tous ces jeunes là on rend le même
service sur seul sur le même territoire
ce qui n'était pas spécialement le cas
aujourd'hui
au total cette fusion concernera plus de
5000 jeunes déscolarisés âgés de 16 à 25
ans présents sur le territoire saint
quentinois